معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
كيف تبدو الاوضاع في ساعات
الصباح
بغزه عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي مازالت
مستمره ومتواصله خاصه في مناطق مختلفه
ربما القصف الاسرائيلي يشمل من بيت حنون
شمالا وحتى رفح جنوبا قصف لم يتوقف منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه ولا دقيقه
واحده لم نشهد يوما لم تنفذ فيه الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه غارات او قصف مدفعي
من الدبابات الاسرائيليه والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على
الحدود الشرقيه سوى ايام قليله هي ايام
الهدنه التي اتفقت عليها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عبر
وسطاء وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
الاشتباكات مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه مستمره
على مدار اليوم على مدار الساعه على مدار
الدقيقه البدايه من شمال القطاع حيث
جباليا التي شهدت قارات اسرائيليه عنيفه
على تلك المناط مناطق منطقه ايضا بيت حنون
وبيت لاهيه شهدت كذلك غارات وقصف مدفعي
عنيف وهذه المناطق ربما هدات فيها حده
الغارات والقصف المدفعي على مدار الايام
الماضيه منذ امس بتنا نشهد عمليات وغارات
اسرائيليه عنيفه على تلك المناطق في شمال
القطاع وايضا قصف مدفعي عنيف بعدما توغلت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه من مناطق ومحاور
انسحبت منها في شمال القطاع القصف ايضا
ممتد الى مدينه غزه حيث المناطق الغربيه
لمدينه غزه مخيم الشاطئ منطقه انصار
ومنطقه الدوار ابو مازن هذه المناطق باتت
تشهد ايضا قصفا عنيفا من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه الدبابات الاسرائيليه ايضا
توغلت بعض الشيء الى هذه المناطق من شارع
الرشيد الى دوار الماليه ودوار ابو مازن
ودوار انصار في مدينه غزه وبالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي يشتد عندما تتوغل الدبابات
الاسرائيليه في تلك المناطق والقصف
المدفعي يستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
بالاضافه الى ان الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تنفذ ما بين فينه واخرى غارات
اسرائيليه على منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وتوقع
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى وعندما نتحدث عن
مدينه غزه دائما نتحدث عن الدمار الهائل
الذي نجم عن الغارات الاسرائيليه في بدايه
الحرب الاسرائيليه وايضا عن القصف المدفعي
والدمار خلال عمليات التوغل الاسرائيلي في
قلب مدينه غزه وبالتالي المنازل التي ظلت
قائمه هي عددها قليل للغايه وبالتالي تكون
مكتظه واي قصف اسرائيلي كل تاكيد يحدث
دمار في هذه المنازل ويوقع عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى وتجري عمليات التمشيط في
كل صباح وينتشل عشرات من الشهداء والجارى
في ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي من الجو
وايضا المدفعي من الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
مخيم النصيرات المناطق الشماليه تشهد
عمليات قصف اسرائيلي وبكل تاكيد في مناطق
التوغل هناك اشتباكات مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه يسمع ما بين الفينه والاخرى
اصوات انفجارات على ما يبدو انها ناجمه عن
اطلاق المقاومه الفلسطينيه لقذائف
وتفجيرها لعبوات لكن القصف الاعنف والاكثر
ضراوه حتى ان الاشتباكات هي اكثر ضراوه
وقصف اعنف وربما هو القصف الاكثر كثافه هو
في مدينه خانيونس خاصه ان مدينه خانيونس
تشهد عمليات توغل من محاور جديده
في محيط مستشفى ناصر كان هناك يسمع اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه ناجمه عن اطلاق القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
في مدينه غزه واخراجها عن الخدمه مستشفى
الشفاء خرج عن الخدمه وبالتالي مستشفى
ناصر بات هو المستشفى الاهم في غزه وهو
المستشفى الاكبر والمستشفى الذي يحتوي على
عدد الاسره الاكبر غرف العمليات الاكثر
الاطباء الاكثر تخصصا وبالتالي تلجا اليه
مستشفيات رفح مستشفيات مدينه مستشفيات دير
البلح مدينه دير البلح وكذلك المخيمات
الوسطى
يحولون المرضى الجرحى بحالات خطيره الى
هذا المستشفى وبالتالي استمرار اطلاق
القذائف في محيط مستشفى ناصر بكل تاكيد
يزيد من الضغط على الاطباء يزيد من الضغط
على الطاقم الطبي وهناك احتماليه لاخراج
هذا المستشفى عن الخدمه اذا استمر هذا
القصف ال غير مباشر في محيط هذا المستشفى
واستهداف الاستهداف والتحريض على المستشفى
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي